welcome to philanthropy in action where
we engage philanthropist activists
students and the community in
discussions on how we use our time
talent and treasure to make the world a
better place I am maxam thorne and I
teach philanthropy in action at Yale
University today's guess is Jesse Fink a
founding partner and a member of the
investment committee of Mission Point
Capital Partners Jesse thank you for
coming thank you thank you for having me
we also have our wonderful Yale
University students as part of our
conversation and I welcome them to the
show beginning with Michael please
introduce yourselves hi I'm Michael
chilson and i'm a senior Religious
Studies major from Chattanooga Tennessee
hi my name is jasmine lau i'm from hong
kong and i'm a senior economics major hi
my name is Steven banks i'm a senior
computer science major from Detroit
Michigan hi I'm Sonia Tillett I'm a
senior in economics and originally from
Zurich Switzerland hi I'm McLean roots
Alomar history major from larkspur
Colorado Thank You Jessie received the
clean tech venture networks leader of
the year award in 2007 this award is
presented to an organization or
individual who has shown exceptional
leadership in adding credibility of or
resources to the clean tech industry
field he and his wife Betsy managed the
Betsy and Jesse Fink foundation which
focuses on catalytic environment and
educational grant making they serve on a
number of nonprofit and startup company
boards Betsy and Jesse have established
and run millstone farm which is
dedicated to producing organic produce
and selling it to local markets and
restaurants millstone serves as a model
for land use and to promote sustainable
agriculture in their community Jesse
it's so exciting to have you participate
with us today the first question like to
ask is how did you get involved in
becoming a philanthropist
well let me first bite start by saying
thank you for having me it really is a
pleasure to be here in an opportunity
and I look forward to the conversation
so thank you I i would say that i began
i didn't really know what philanthropy
was until i actually had access to some
dollars to give away and that was after
the public offering of priceline and
when that happened Betsy and I were
fortunate enough to have some wealth and
we realized that we wanted to give back
and so we started studying philanthropy
and started studying great families and
what they were doing and that was back
in about two thousand and you and Betsy
and it was so wonderful to meet your
lovely wife that's who is also here with
us in our in our studio studio and so
Thank You Betsy for for being here when
you came into wealth did that pose a
challenge with in in terms of what you
were going to do with it in discussing
this with Betsy and your family and how
old were your kids at that time well
those are such great questions there I
believe our kids were probably eight and
ten roughly at that time and it posed a
lot of questions when you work for a
private company and the company goes
public and IPO going public means lots
of things become public and so we were
part of that wave the first wave of
Internet companies and so it was very
overwhelming to us to figure out we knew
that we wanted to give back to the world
we knew we wanted to focus on
environmental issues because we met in
forestry college as undergrads and
always had a passion for the environment
and so we knew that that's what our
focus was going to be but we had no idea
of what it meant to give money away I
think prior to the year 2000 2001 our
largest
charitable gift might have been two
hundred and fifty dollars and all of a
sudden we were propelled into a new
world and didn't really have a lot of
chance no one told us what to expect we
weren't trained for that and you realize
how many new friends you can establish
when they know that there's something
that you can make donations to their
favorite causes so it was a it was
overwhelming I think we we knew a course
that we wanted to make we experimented
quite a bit which I hope we have a
chance to talk about because we've
learned a lot over these 10 or 11 years
now you said something that I find
fascinating which is that you looked at
other philanthropists and who had a
history of giving but your particular
experience which was having been part of
a start-up a very successful one
priceline you brought a whole new set of
skills and talents that really wasn't
part of the conversation I would guess
among the people you were looking at or
was it absolutely right we you know we
were fortunate very fortunate to be part
of this first wave of of wealth creation
around turn of the century and when we
went studied other families there are
families like the Rockefeller family
which we spent a lot of time meeting
family members of the Rockefellers and
and actually having advisors who had
worked with the Rockefeller family so we
learned a lot from great families and
also learned lots from families that
perhaps were not as successful in their
philanthropy and also in their families
and I think your first question is very
important because with families and
family philanthropy there there needs to
be a connection between the two and we
come across many people where that isn't
the case where there you know excellent
in philanthropy but not necessarily
paying attention to their family and you
have choose children two children what
are their ages our son drew is 22 and
our daughter Carly is 20 just couple
other sort of demographic questions
where did you go to school as a child I
grew up on Long Island and went to
elementary school in high school in
Valley Stream New York how about kind of
schools were they they were basic Long
Island public schools public schools and
Betsy Betsy grew up in ithaca new york
and graduated from ithaca high school
uh-huh and did you ever do religious go
to religious schools yeah I I did there
was a white castle near where our temple
was and so we probably visited the White
Castle as much as we visit a temple and
I think Betsy had a similar experience
in horizon because one of the
fascinating things that we observe is
any contact with early religious
institutions seems to affect people's
giving do you think that that's a
connection or is it not in your case now
i don't i don't think so i think for
both of us and we really are a team and
you'll hear me mostly talk about we and
us and if i talk about I it's probably a
mistake but both of us did not have a
lot of religious training but we grew up
with families that were strong families
and I think with the sense of that there
was a bigger world out there that we
needed to participate in and to give
back and so it was very natural for us
when we realized that we had an
opportunity to do wonderful things in
the world to figure out how we would
make that happen and now we go to our
religious studies major Michael I feel
like I should ask your religion question
oh yeah I was so I sort of as a young
environmentalist I think came of age at
a time when there was a sense of the
death of environmentalism I'm that as an
ideological movement environmentalism
was was breaking down or showing itself
to be to be to not be working i'm
curious whether you see sort of the
capital side of what you do the
investing as a continuation of
environmentalism or are these separate
things as one more effective than the
other I think you have to do it all and
iris actually was up here at Yale when
the two gentlemen who proved presented
the essay of death of environmentalism
first came out and and they were
brilliant and it was controversial
what they did the reason why we make
investments environmental investments is
we believe that it is an important
component of solving the problems that
the environmental problems that we are
facing are so large they can't be solved
entirely with traditional grant-making
and philanthropy and so we believe that
making investments in clean energy and
sustainable agriculture and all and and
other things outside of our expertise
are an important mix and complement
traditional grant maker that's your
answer did I answer it yeah they do you
think there was the place for that type
of or where's the place went in the
cabinet what were the XT investment
model is less effective or more
effective than philanthropy all right
right I think that that you need both
ran and basic philanthropy which is to
me traditional flavors grant-making
where foundations like ours are making a
grant to nonprofits there it is it's a
grant it is an investment we're making
an investment in an organization but we
are not getting a financial return we
are only hoping that there is an impact
return a mission return of what's going
on there are many instances where that's
not enough and and many of the
organizations that we work with in the
environmental world realized probably
about 10 years ago that grant making
isn't enough an example is the Nature
Conservancy one of the largest
environmental organizations and a great
organization that we support they you
know they have a very large budget that
comes from philanthropy but to save the
land that they need to save for
biodiversity all around the world is far
greater the dollars needed a far greater
than they're going to get from
fundraising so they need to find other
pools of capital they need to find folks
who will invest as opposed to or in
addition to just donate or they'll find
individuals who own land who will treat
their land responsibly so this new world
that we're living in that today is
called impact investing which is where I
spend a lot of time is really the
interest
section of finding out where there's
traditional grant-making we're in
between that and where there's purely
for profit investing that has no social
or environmental return where we are is
in the middle and there's a really need
need for all of that happening do you
find yourself more engaged and Betsy
more engaging monitoring your grant
making functions and the recipients of
those grants or your investment
functions the recipient of those grants
or your private investments and whoever
you're investing in right well luckily
we have a wonderful team of
professionals in all of those pieces and
John Briggs is sitting there next to
Betsy and really is at the core of on
the philanthropic side on the
grant-making side and on the investment
side we have a team of folks internally
and externally I would say that I
probably should be spending more of my
time on our personal portfolio but I
realized there isn't that much that I
can do we have invested with very
qualified people and we monitor that so
I spend most of my time on the
philanthropic grant-making and the
philanthropic investments which which we
are calling impact investments and and
of that time it's more on the what I'll
call the origination and due diligence
ID which is figuring out what are the
problems that we're trying to solve and
who are the right organizations that we
want to work through I'm more interested
in that once we do that and do do that
work and we make an investment or make a
grant I personally am a little less
interested in the monitoring and the
follow-up but that's just the way and
now we go to our you cannot mix nature
Jasmine I have a related question with
impact investing and also clean
technology which is something you're
very interested and I know technology is
something that gets people very excited
by the same time sometimes it comes with
risks and problems of its own and I was
curious too
see like for example what do you think
about you know how to approach
technology in the context of its
implementation it usually comes with you
know it needs to be effective it also
comes with policy and like behavioral
changes and how does impact investing
plays into those but I should just
applaud you all on these great questions
there let me let me put impact of
investing aside for a second and just
focus on technology and how technology
affects in the sector in the clean
energy first of all that the main thing
that we focus on is the environment and
within the environment a lot of our
focus has been on climate change and
Betsy and I share we share everything
and then when we do our own things
Betsy's more focused on sustainable
agriculture and really at the community
level and for the last eight years I
have been very focused on global climate
change and our son Drew who's 22 and his
friends have heard this conversation
often because as we get as we get groups
of kids together we have a conversation
about how technology might solve some of
these environmental issues technology
isn't going to solve global climate
change its is not it technology can
hopefully slow down some of the future
issues that are going to happen by
burning fossil fuels but it's not unless
we come up with some really amazing geo
engineering we're not going to reverse
the damage that has occurred from the
way we have been using energy that's my
opinion I think that most people would
in the scientific world agree with that
technology is is very important consumer
behavior and is really really important
and if you bring it down to a specific
level something like smart meters which
is a great technology but if people
aren't going to change their behavior
and how they use a smart meter you could
put a smart
in everybody's house and they can put
that smart meter at 85 degrees and not
naked it'll be a smart meter doing the
wrong things so you have to look at all
of that and through our investment side
and through our philanthropy side we
look at technology we look at business
models and business model innovation we
look at consumer acceptance to the
various different technologies and all
of that leads to policy and policy is an
incredible part of everything that's
going on and in the energy sector policy
is key and when we first started doing
all of this on the philanthropy side and
on the investment side we were not as
concerned about policy and we realized
that we actually need to be and so over
the years we have become more and more
engaged on the on the policy side that
answer your question how do you cuz I
know you and Betsy have a little bit of
difference between policy and politics
yes how do you and she determine the
distinction between those those areas
right well maybe I should walk into why
we even got into policy and then how we
even got slightly into politics it's not
it really wasn't by choice we started
off by saying we want to work on
environmental issues and as we started
studying environmental issues we
realized that policy was such a key part
of it whether it's land conservation or
energy use or agriculture or food policy
as what drives at all and then as you
start becoming a student of policy you
realize that there's politics that's
really behind the policy that's how
policy gets written it gets changed by
the politics and so we sort of morphed
perhaps me more so than betsy morphed
into the politics side said look if we
really want to make a difference we
probably need to figure out the politics
and so for a couple years we were fairly
engaged in the politics thinking that it
would really make a difference and we
are less engaged at this point in time
because yes it does make a difference
but we've realized that that's not an
area that we
to spend that much time on you have to
really dedicate yourself to the politics
side and and that's not who we are I
think we are more want to get our hands
dirty Betsy literally in the ground in
me in working with companies or with
small organizations and we do support
policy and organizations large
environmental organizations that are
pushing the policy of course it's key
but I think we have backed off a little
bit the last couple years Steven hi so
when a traditional capitalists plans to
invest in an opportunity or considers
investing in an opportunity he or she
may predict a range of possible outcomes
and assign a probability to each of
those outcomes to what extent do you do
the same thing when looking to invest in
a impact invest in a company or make a
grant to a non-profit and how feasible
is doing such a thing well I think that
it's see I think it's I don't know if I
would use the word easier but it's being
a traditional investor as you would use
the word you're being measured by a
financial return and it's fairly easy to
measure the financial return if you're
investing in a company you know what is
the profitability of the company if that
company nowhere if you invest at a
certain level and then you exit at a
certain level what was your return on
capital that's been done for thousands
of years impact investing is new because
it really people used to make grants and
then they would make investments and
it's only been recently that we put it
together and it's complicated because
you can look at the financial return but
that's not why you're making investment
you're making investment because of the
impact as well and i would say that we
probably do the do the same due
diligence and rigor on a pure financial
investment that we do on an impact
investment from the financial side
because it needs to work financially you
have to make a set of assumptions and
you hope that you're going to be within
that range of assumptions from a
financial return on the impact side
there again this is kind of a new area
and
there's all these different forms of
measurement i would say on that part we
are less measurement focused so that we
look when we're making investments and
again this is really coming from our
foundation that's making impact
investments and I need to differentiate
that from Mission Point which is a firm
that is focused on financial returns but
making investments in a world of clean
energy in our foundation we are making
investments and we are looking at a
financial return but we also are looking
to make an impact the impact that we
like to make is really being a catalyst
so the way we would measure the impact
would be if we made an investment did
other people make an investment
afterwards did we actually test out a
innovative business model was there a
gap in the in the investment
infrastructure of some sort that we
plugged the gap with our small
investment and as a result of that we
proved that a model and other people
came behind us and made a similar
investment that's the way we measure it
if we were successful other people are
coming into the market larger dollars
are coming into the market and
eventually the risks that might have
been associated with the investment we
made will have gone down because
everybody will have proved out the risks
and once the risks go down there's a lot
of capital that can come into the market
people want to come in they're just they
have a different risk profile than a
small family foundation Winston
Churchill see if this applies to you in
this what you're doing has a famous
saying but I quote in a different
context which is above my life which is
success is going from failure to failure
but with enthusiasm doesn't apply in
this space that's it that's a great
quote we you have to have enthusiasm you
know you have to as a as an entrepreneur
which is what I've been most of my life
you're running on enthusiasm you know
you need to stand up in front of a group
of people and tell them that the company
is really going to be fantastic and then
you go home at night and you cry and you
hope
really going to me so you have to you
know and I think by nature we both are
enthusiastic people and you need to have
failures if you haven't failed then you
haven't learned and or maybe that's us
right if you fail it doesn't necessarily
mean you learned if you you know and we
fail often but hopefully when we fail
the next failure is it's not the same
way and we have learned from the first
failure oh yeah and we actually even
have code names you know if we did
something and it failed the next time
something comes up we'll say amongst the
three of us or amongst the investment
team oh yeah that's like a blah blah
blah okay we'll stay away from that so
you you need to fail I think failure and
risk are really important and that's the
way that things grow if not we're just
all going to be in a fairly steady state
do you think that particular way of
thinking about failure comes from your
entrepreneurial background and is that
different then then then people who have
been engaged in a different kind of
philanthropy or came at philanthropy
from an inheritor perspective yes it's
very different because our wealth was
created by taking personal risks and
career risks and acting a certain way
for 15 or 20 years in our professional
career and we had a lot of luck and
success in fate and it worked and so
that model worked for us and so we're
actually using that same model in in our
philanthropy if it's a and we could do
that because it's the Betsy and Jesse
Fink foundation and we are you know we
can make those decisions we buy by all
the rules and guidelines need to happen
but there's not a lot of bureaucracy in
fact whenever we feel like there's some
bureaucracy creeping into our small
little foundation it just it makes us
nervous and we need to figure how to do
it we do have good governance and so I
think we have great reports and great
accountability but we like to keep it
small other foundations that are second
generation or third generation that the
founders of that the creators of the
wealth or not there are in a very
different situation in that case they
have a different responsibilities to be
more
the stewards of that wealth and make
sure that they're following whatever was
written down as the guidelines for the
philanthropy on how they're going to
distribute that for us we wrote things
down but we can change it we can change
it every year we look at and say what
are the issues the sub issues that we
want to focus on this year okay how are
we going to do that it just we we are
able to run our organization a lot more
fluidly and entrepreneur because that's
that's who we are at the stage 20 years
from now are our foundation if it's
still if we haven't given it all away
we'll be in a different different
situation one of our guests who made a
lot of wealth from creating the trio and
the Palm Pilot Donna dibinsky makes the
argument that that is why she is engaged
right now she's alive and she's vibrant
in being engaged in philanthropy and
those decisions and addressing the
question of does she do it all now and
spend it all now while she is here or
does she pass it on for some future
generation or her children are you
grappling with that because clearly
there's a benefit for you and Betsy
being engaged right now and being able
to to course-correct and alter and it's
a difference when other people will be
stewarding this if in fact you choose
for other people just doing this is some
point in the future how have you
resolved that yourself we talked about
it quite often and I would say if we had
to make a decision now we would say that
we want to do as much as we can do while
we're alive and we're engaged and that
for us we don't need to leave a legacy
of a foundation that that our family or
other professional people are
administering on our behalf if it turns
out that our children have an interest
in getting engaged in that then that
would be wonderful and at that point in
time it I would suggest that it should
be what their passions are and not
necessarily trying to live out our
passions so for now
our feeling is we're here it gives us
great pleasure to be working with
organizations small nonprofit
organizations large nonprofit
organizations and to give as much as we
can of our time and of our finances to
to make it happen it's a maturing
process for us and in if I see you in a
couple years we may be thinking
differently but a snapshot of today I
think this is what that would i'd say
sudden um sorry I'm wondering we've
touched multiple times on the fact that
you've been an entrepreneur and that's
really actually what still defines you
and I'm wondering working with
nonprofits which you know maybe don't
have a specially web enterpreneurship
you know where you sort of go from
ideation to rapid prototyping to the
alpha version be diversion and you just
try to get through that pipeline really
quickly and and and and I think that's a
very different focus from some
nonprofits which and especially
environmentalism where the timeline is
just completely different you know how
do you are you how do you deal with your
impatience because because I can you
know I can see myself I'm very involved
with with multiple projects and I love
pushing things forward and I get very
impaired and I've been worked for
nonprofit myself and I clearly know that
it's probably not for me it while I'm
yet while I'm you know before I'm 30
because I be too impatient about it I
really want to see this thing happen now
well something i said earlier which is
when you're making a grant to a
non-profit you are making an investment
in that nonprofit you're just
recognizing that you're not getting a
financial return so if you're going to
make an investment in a non-profit
there's a whole decision process that
you're going to say why should it be
this dumb profit versus net nonprofit
within a non-profit which activity
should I be supporting I think for Betsy
and I the nonprofit's the large
nonprofits that we work with know what
we're all about and they come up to see
us as their venture investors in some
ways and we're very proud of the
that we have done with the largest
nonprofits but with small innovative
projects and and so we'll sit down with
the CEO of Fred Krupp as an example of
Environmental Defense or Francis by
Nokia NRDC and many others and they'll
say hey this is a project that where we
want to work on or we'll sit Betsy and I
on will set them and say hey this is
something that we think you should be
working on and we'll talk about it and
if there is an opportunity for us to
provide seed investment to that project
will do that and we we probably do five
of those a year and again if we're
successful then our seed dollars will
lead to other organizations other
foundations getting behind that and
we've done that a stream of that and I
think we've got a good reputation so
that when we do this other foundations
will say all right well if you know
Betsy and Jesse are in it well then
we'll take a look at it as well the
impatience the proud the problems that
they're trying to solve are really
really long problems and I am impatient
and I think over the years I realized
you're just not going to get the result
I thought climate change I actually
thought that there was going to be a
bill passed and I you know like so many
other folks in our sector we really did
and we were almost there and then it
didn't happen and and actually on that
note we all kind of walked away after
Copenhagen fell apart and said now what
do we do you know for eight years this
was our defining moment it was going to
have it and everyone walked myself what
do we do now and and I think all of us
as philanthropists retrenched and said
what do we do what we did was we kind of
went local we said you know what for a
moment let's just stay off of this
global change or our platform because I
don't think we really made a difference
but we can locally and so you can really
see when you're doing something locally
when you're touching a one student or a
community in your backyard or you or
even internationally and you can see
that it made a difference it could
happen but what I would say is as an
entrepreneur and as as investors in
philanthropy
we're backing people so within an
organization we tend to gravitate to the
one who's the entrepreneurial in there
you know and and they know it the large
organizations you know will put out this
person in front of us because they know
that we can we can relate to them and
will typically find a project that we
can support and the result of that
project will have so global climate
change is a big problem and who knows
how it's ever going to get resolved but
actually figuring out how to do
renewable energy in new haven or in
Bridgeport or doing urban gardens in new
haven and Bridgeport or elsewhere in the
world you can touch it you can feel it
and you can see the result and you could
get behind in a social entrepreneur and
do whatever you can to make them
successful can I follow up did you want
to know but just because you mentioned
how you you know having almost been
there with the bill and then that
disappointment yeah I was fortunate
enough to just three days ago I learned
that I'm able to go to the
sustainability conference in Rio oh
great that plus 20 and I I think there's
you know I think a lot of people are
looking to it especially in light of all
soaked up 15 yeah you know what are your
hopes for this conference I think the
sort of the cynical view which says well
the time of big conference is sort of
over yeah and then there's sort of a
hopeful view which says well you know we
got a shot at it again and after all
it's rio and it's it's been that 20
years so who knows what is your take on
it well I this is where I could actually
give you a really political answer that
probably I shouldn't yeah you know there
has to be there has to be a political
will what I found in in Copenhagen in
the whole process is that the rest of
the world still looks to the United
States to be a leader migraine be really
great and so in Copenhagen you know we
were trying to do that at that point in
time and then we backed off and and so a
lot of what was the progress I was made
up to that point is going backwards
because it's it all needs to come
together and it wasn't so the United
States has to figure out again how to
lead and
and what does that mean and what shape
does that take different than a large
conference so I'm not sure what will
come out of that conference but i do
think to tie it back to some of the
questions on the investment side if you
can get different constituents paying
attention to environmental issues in
addition to the traditional
environmental list in the world of
philanthropy i believe three percent of
dollars go to environmental issues right
or to origin it's a very very small
number think we discussed this early on
on class right so and we you know what
we probably know where all those dollars
are coming over a small group of funders
but if you look at poverty in World
Health and other issues they're much
bigger these issues are the same issues
you know the issues of poverty and water
when you look at climate change and the
things that are happening and will be
happening with droughts and floods and
we're seeing it with natural disasters
it really needs to be the intersection
and the environmental community and they
did in Copenhagen and can neatly to
continue to have a much wider tent to
realize that you know it's not about the
environment we live on this earth and we
all live us on this earth and we need to
figure out how to how to coexist in the
positive way so I'm not sure exactly
what's going to come out of that but I
where I'm optimistic I'm optimistic with
your generation I'm optimistic that that
there's so many younger folks who are
figuring out how they want to do things
in their own way and whether they're
starting a for-profit company that they
want to make money we talked to someone
today that has a software platform for
organic farms and for csa so that's a
for-profit business or social
entrepreneurs folks like 350.org that
are running around trying to organize
people and i'm sure there's great groups
here at Yale so I'm optimistic that that
your generation understands the
complexities of what's going on and and
will take a leadership role in our
generation will do everything we can to
support your f
and our philanthropy a lot of it is
going to start up early stage nonprofits
that have a different twist on how they
want to do things are collaborating with
a larger nonprofit so they get to
understand those pieces of it that's
that's where I think the future is there
certainly things need to happen at a
global level but I think it's going to
be a lot of bubbling up and eventually
the leadership our leadership in
Washington will look behind and realize
that your folks like you are pushing
them forward into the right decisions
it's it's it's exciting right to feel
your enthusiasm and and Sony's question
because 20 years ago when I graduated
law school I was part of the rio summit
then and I spent they don't know this
but I said three years of my life the
most boring part of my life believe it
or not even though I was excited about
the issues of the earth summit on
treaties yeah that came out of the earth
summit so I worked on you know the
United Nations biodiversity Convention
and climate change convention in bonds
or the best part was traveling around
the world and transboundary move them to
have of hazardous waste and population
in Egypt and you know etc but what you
said is also true I mean I remember
ambassador Holbrooke great guy and it
was the Clinton administration but it
there was no will to make this happen on
the international stage and after three
years of doing this I didn't have the
enthusiasm that you're showing 20 years
later and came back to the states to do
something different and quite local and
how do you keep up that level of
enthusiasm over this time and I know
that you're also doing very creative
things right now in your investments
investing in interns and in fellowships
how do you do that how do you keep that
passion enthusiasm that I did lose I'm
so committed right I just can't bear the
the the day-to-day grind of it right
you know what I think part of it is
being here today there's you get
recharged you know I think we all have
internal batteries and you have to
figure out how to get that battery
recharged my battery gets recharged by
by younger people or entrepreneurial
people of any age when when someone has
that energy and enthusiasm and you feel
like you can help them what they're
trying to do it recharges you and so if
you can give a little to somebody and
you're getting a little back from that
it's just then the whole system works
your comment about interns and fellows
is something Betsy and I have been
funding through the foundation we have
every year we have funded a handful of
interns and fellows and this year we've
made a concentrated effort to really
scale that up and with a focus on
climate change adaptation in the past
organizations nonprofits would come to
us and say would you fund an intern here
and in turn there and we did that and
never really even knew many cases who
the interns are what their names were
and what they were doing we're learning
a lot from your generation of the
connectivity and we felt that this year
we're going to create a program and we
are going to be funding over 30 interns
and fellows in over 20 organizations
they're going to be working in those
organizations but they will loosely be
part of of a network and what we hope is
that our energy will be you know
energized from those individuals but we
really hope is that this network of
students who are all passionate and all
have an interest in climate change
adaptation and resiliency are charged up
by themselves and often in the in the
for-profit and entrepreneurial world or
in the nonprofit world you know there
are days that you're up and there are
many days that you're down and if you're
surrounding yourself with other positive
people when you're down someone will
pull you back up I think for Betsy and I
we've you know we're going to be married
30 years the summer and that's a lot of
the partnership and the relationship
that we have is when someone
excited and someone's lesso figuring out
how to pull the other person that I'm
sorry but we have to be actually be just
there we have no choice you know and and
so surrounding yourselves with with
inspiring people and finding a way that
you can figure out how you can provide
value to people around you that that's
what it's what the world's all about but
you had questions I have many fun I'm
not really sure where to start what's
really exciting it's really inspiring to
hear you say that and it's deciding to
hear that your funding 30 interns that's
that's incredible i wish i would have
been about that earlier we have room for
more i have i have several questions but
going back to you funding locally and
going back to you know kind of getting
your hands dirty in and you were
mentioning Bridgeport Connecticut which
is nearby New Haven and we're actually
looking into an organization wholesome
wave that one of our one of our students
is supporting and you know I've read a
little bit on wholesome wave but I was
curious why you chose to to find help
you know help fund a wholesome wave and
how that is worked out for you and what
you know that's been successful or kind
of what are you guys am I going to bias
the decision let me get contacts the
students are fully empowered at the end
of this semester to give away a hundred
thousand dollars right so they have been
designing their metrics they've been
analyzing various philanthropies and
charities local national international
and and part of what they're grappling
with the questions that you could
actually help them answer about why you
chose some wave and so forth so so feel
free ok let me ask you is is the hundred
thousand dollars it's all it's all going
to one organization no we can choose if
we look like oh I think looking at the
ads that we had we chose every age
student ranked all the organizations
last night actually so right in the
midst of it and I think looking at the
different summaries put up by each
student cuz each student is supporting
an organization there are certain sums
that each organization is specifically
asking for which I thought was really
great you know one organizations looking
for thirty thousand dollars to start a
specific program I think it's exciting
looking at how these organizations are
deciding to spend this money they're
very they know
exactly what they want they they know
exactly what they want to get done and
what projects they want to fund and so I
think we'll end up funding several
organizations and pull some waves in
this bunch so we'll see you well let me
just say I hope you do fund wholesome
wave they are phenomenal organizations
by the way yeah if organizations get a
match it helps them well what do you say
well we'll have a committee meeting it's
true all right it's true because the
leveraging is okay was a big part advise
into your idea of who else is following
this oh we will match wholesome with we
will match whatever you do for wholesome
way if you so we'll do that we have got
the nod thank you Betty Jo um you know
wholesome wave is an example of a lot of
the questions you were asking me in the
comments that I was trying to respond to
about an organization Michelle Nashawn
who is the founder of wholesome wave is
an amazing guy and he was has been and
still is a chef has been for his whole
life he has started many different
restaurants many different businesses so
he understands operations in a
understands business he's been involved
in this healthy food movement for 25
years he's the east coast version of
Alice Waters it's a phenomenal guy and
has made a personal career decision to
get off of the path of restaurant
stardom in some ways and focus his all
of his efforts he still owns a
restaurant and manages it but all of his
other efforts in wholesome wave and we
we were seed funders of wholesome wave
so we we probably were the first money
that they got and then Paul Newman the
Newman's Own foundation was right there
as well and since then we have every
every chance we can we are their funding
Michelle we're and we're doing
in some cases we fund just put money and
to keep the lights on because that needs
to happen and and I don't want to leave
the impression that all we do or is
looking for projects we realized that
organizations need capacity just to pay
for the people in talent they have and
we've done that with Michelle but he
also as an example where every year we
were talking about one or two new things
we can do the double value coupon
program which was what got them started
was a program that they were looking at
down in Washington about double value
and actually remember where it was in
our conference room or up on the farm
and we were talking and and Betsy was
set to Michelle all right we'll double
the double value so at that point time
just as what's happening here is they
had a great idea but it the economics
didn't quite work and so the incentive
of doubling the double it was really
what made to take off and as a result of
that other foundations going back to
geography a foundation in San Diego and
a foundation in Detroit and the
foundation in Louisville said okay we'll
double that and we'll double that and
we'll double that so our initial grant
and the way we did it was a way to get
other people going and that's you know
that was Betsy's idea sitting in the
conference room and Betsy joined the
board and so we know what's going on
there we were very involved with
Michelle he was in our office yesterday
talking about new ideas they're a great
organization low overhead truly
committed people the folks that they're
hiring are coming from all different
types of sectors and they've they're
really getting to the core of what the
issues are so I'm probably talking too
much about them in particular but they
they answer if you look at a checklist
of the type of organizations that we
want to support that are in the newer
type they are at the top of the list and
Jesse could you help us understand
something but when you said low overhead
right how do you determine what is no
overhead for a startup what is low
overhead when you're getting to scale
their budget has sort of tripled or
quadrupled in a very short space of time
and their overhead has changed
it's ratio dramatically over time all
right help us understand how you think
of that because we could take a
different view as we look at that and
wonder is this really a good ratio a
good balance of overhead versus what
you're actually doing right I I would
caution you if you're having that
conversation by looking at a spreadsheet
in numbers and not talking to an
organization then you might get a static
picture and it may not truly show what's
going on and so in this case keeping
them over a low overhead is giving
furniture to Michelle so he can do that
he you know folks taking half the salary
that they could get somewhere else
figuring out how you know how they can
have meetings in places where they don't
have to pay for it so they're they're a
scrappy entrepreneurial new organization
but the talent that they're bringing in
is is high level professional Talent
that makes us very confident that
they're going to accomplish the things
they have and they have accomplished
what they did I want to also address
that because the this is cutting-edge
stuff because one of the things that you
are willing to do I think I hear you say
is pay for talent yes oftentimes people
assume that if you're involved in
philanthropy you're taking a vow of
poverty right and it's hard to attract
talent you're trying to resolve the
world's greatest problems on the cheap
right how is it and this is what I think
you also bring to this conversation that
if you want talent you must be willing
to pay for you mean do you agree with
that is that part of your philosophy
yeah I i think that there's a new
paradigm that's happening which is the
potential employee is willing to work
for slightly less than they would in a
down in Wall Street per se because they
want to work for an organization that
they believe is doing something you know
that's aligned with their mission and I
think organizations realize they need to
pay a little bit more for that talent
and so I see that happening i see it
whether it's small companies or in the
large environmental group
they're bringing people in from people
who've come up from nonprofits but also
people who have come from the private
sector because it's it's a different
world and this this feeling of here's
the nonprofit over here and here's the
for profit I think people you know in
aren't generations anyway I want to do
something I'll do something that's good
and and they're doing it people in their
50s are leaving their first career and
they're going to that you guys get a
chance to do it the first time around so
I am fascinated with what you've been
saying and I'm actually very inspired by
your comments and as you mentioned
earlier about possible interns I wanted
to ask you you know as as a as a student
and as students out of liberal arts
school at Yale it and as I mean as an
art history major myself I haven't
really had the ability or that the
opportunity to pursue my interest in
food except for you know extra
extracurricular kinds of things and you
know what is your advice for us as young
people you said you know you you
appreciate enthusiasm what what is your
advice for us and how we can pursue our
interests in philanthropy and in
pursuing pursuing this this this area of
food dresses that is just up and coming
and it's really exciting well that's a
great question it's a great question you
know I mentioned earlier we have 22
children our son graduated last year
from Stanford and our daughter is a
sophomore middlebury and getting you
know very similar liberal arts education
and a great education there and that's
when I as i mentioned went to forestry
school which is a very technical school
so I didn't didn't have the experience
that you guys had the educational
experience I think there's tremendous
opportunity for you to get started and
what we have said to our children and
what they've done is to try to grab
whether it's it's an intern an unpaid
internship if it had to be or a paid
internship or just volunteering even on
a more ad hoc level just to get started
and to see what what works what doesn't
work for you what type of organization
feels right but
I would say that this movement that
you're mentioning which is really part
of a whole larger movement that I think
your generation is is fueling which
isn't come on you know we want to do
something here and so there are a lot of
social entrepreneurs and many are
actually starting their own thing in
which case you have a whole other set of
challenges which has got to go get
funding which is fun and exciting but
it's just like starting a business it is
a business it's just a non-profit
business and a lot of folks are going
with with smaller organizations that
recently started like a wholesome wave
or large organizations large
organizations like an NRDC that are
large they've been around for a long
time but I tell you they're constantly
innovating because they they have to be
so if you know what your what your
passion is i guess i would say that it
is to my kids the yes them the words
that we've said it passion passion
passion of yours but if you follow that
it will work you know if you put
yourself in play and you find an
organization here in new haven or your
hometown or if there's a part of the
world that you want to live you go there
and you put yourself out there and it'll
I imagine it'll it'll happen and maybe
that sounds a little you know fairy dust
or something but I I believe that as
someone who's hired just a lot of people
along the way you know you could look at
a resume and see a college that somebody
went to what their studies were if you
get a chance to actually sit with
someone and they're and they're jumping
out of the chair you can you could see
it in your eyes you know you could you
could feel it coming from somebody
that's what it needs someone who's
hiring and actually in our early days in
priceline again this was 1996-1997 their
early early days of internet there were
not people who were HTML program you
know there were not especially we were
in Stanford Connecticut everybody was
out you know in the west coast we were
doing it kind of by ourselves and we
hired just the people who were excited
you know they were they didn't they
didn't know what they didn't know and we
hired him and we created an environment
and Betsy was there we just created an
environment that said we can make thing
happen and people didn't little donno
year later they actually became an
expert in HTML or database programming
or whatever else so I think that if you
present yourself and and your spirit
comes out and your passion comes out you
could find the organizations that you
that are doing things that you want to
do that's great the other thing I would
say which may sound like it's contrary
to that is at a young age you're also
collecting skills so it's almost like a
construction person who's got a tool
chest and you're going around and
collecting schools or skills or maybe
it's the different games that you can
play now where you're collecting things
so whoever that is but that's what you
should be doing to is is if you can't
find the perfect opportunity perfect
organization if you think to yourself
what skills do I need in the next five
years what skills do I need and go find
an organization that may not be the
perfect organization but if it's a place
that you can go and you can work a year
or two years and give up yourself and
make sure that they're getting their
value from you and you're learning
something and you're learning and it
could be learning sales and marketing or
it could be learning learning creative
or could be learning speaking public
speaking things like that that's what at
your stage in life you're on this
journey and you should be getting great
experiences and gaining great skills and
with every position that you take you're
just learning something more that's
going to make you more valuable and
enhance your your value to the world for
the next thing that you go on so we know
and we spend best thing I spend look
lately but spending like more time with
our son's friends than our Sun which I
and and listening to them you know and
they're all looking for the perfect job
and we're essentially saying you know
you may not find the perfect job but
find a place that feels right the
culture feels right do that you're
working with people that you that you
trust that you have respect for that are
honest and ethical and then that you've
given an opportunity to go prove
yourself and give to that organization
whether it's for-profit or nonprofit
learn from that organization and then
your life will just be a collection of
those career
experiences that yes helpful okay
earlier this afternoon you said why are
you here why did we want you and the
reason we wanted you is exactly this
this conversation with a new generation
of philanthropists they are committed
they are engaged and they're excited and
I think you bring a a new set of
thoughts and an enthusiasm that has been
so inspiring Yale has obviously been
doing something incredibly innovative
with with this where we're teaching
philanthropy and empowering the students
to design their own metrics to do their
own research follow their own passions
and and it's so good to have you sharing
that so thank you so very much for
coming in today and even though we can't
see her but thank you Ben Z and thank
you Joe for being part of of this
wonderful moment in Yale's philanthropy
thank you it's it's been a wonderful
afternoon so thank you very much and
thank you students for for joining us
this has been philanthropy in action we
all have a part to play in making the
world a better place as Jesse thing said
it's passion it's passion and take it
with enthusiasm now what are you going
to do to change the world